[Music]
the Xbox one enjoyed a strong third year
on the market with an expanding
backwards-compatibility catalog Xbox
play anywhere support and a nice system
revision its software lineup was no
slouch either with some strong
exclusives and an even stronger array of
multi-platform games Ward's of horizon 3
is one such game building on the
foundations of the previous two horizon
titles it offers a tremendous amount of
variety for a racer it's Australian
setting provides a wide array of diverse
locations to explore letting you
seamlessly drive between the outback
jungles beaches and the countryside
there are a ton of different things to
do throughout horizon threes open-world
you might wander off the beaten path to
search for a hidden car take part in an
impromptu race smash a hard-to-reach
billboard set a new high speed or drift
record or simply stop to take in the
sights horizon 3 is one of the best
looking games of the year on any
platform
[Music]
Dishonored 2 builds on the foundation of
its predecessor with a more believable
world intelligent AI and a choice of two
playable characters each with their own
distinct skills what it lacks in terms
of difficulty and interesting
storytelling it more than makes up for
with some brilliantly conceived levels
and opportunities for experimentation
prior to release director Harvey Smith
described how play testers had combined
powers in ways that developers hadn't
considered it's easy to spend hours
playing around with the myriad
possibilities that exist in his review
GameSpot Scott Butterworth even
describes Dishonored 2 as being as much
a toy box as it is a game it's also one
of those games that sticks with you
after you're done playing for the day
it'll keep you up at night as you relive
your conquests and contemplate the
alternative approaches you could have
taken
a frequent criticism of the first
titanfall was the lack of a real
single-player mode titanfall 2 more than
answers the call providing us with a
well-paced story in some of the most
memorable moments and levels of the year
it also manages to make you genuinely
care about your Titan counterpart even
if the writing isn't as strong as it
could be this emphasis on single-player
didn't come at the expense of the strong
multiplayer that titanfall is known for
titanfall 2 introduces new progression
systems that give you ample reasons to
keep you coming back there are also
distinct new Titans including one that
can wield a sword and another that
reigns explosive fighter down on your
enemies throughout all of this titanfall
2 can also boast about having arguably
the smoothest most natural movement and
controls in any shooter on the market in
a game where you can walk around in a
huge mecha nile aiding your foes the
fact that running or wall running is
still so much fun is a testament to
respawns design work
battlefield one is another Xbox one
shooter that surprised everyone by
including a strong single-player
component alongside its quality
multiplayer mode single-player content
has never been developer dices strong
suit but by dividing battlefield ones
campaign into five disparate stories it
was able to make each storyline only as
long as it needed to be
it tells real human stories that stay
grounded by not turning characters into
superheroes and they didn't all have
happy endings
battlefield ones campaign does a far
better job of conveying the horrors of
war than any previous game in this
series its multiplayer doesn't aspire to
do the same thing instead taking the
established battlefield formula in
evolving it and that's not a bad thing
battlefield 1 offers the most dynamic
matches the series has ever seen thanks
to map dominating behemoth vehicles and
weather effects that force you to alter
your tactics
overwatch represents blizzards first
foray into shooters as it did with mmo's
collectible card games and everything
else
Blizzard offers a unique take on the
genre that streamlines a concept but not
at the expense of depth the interplay
between its 23 characters and counting
remains as interesting as it did on
launch day matches can change on the fly
not just because of players using their
Ultimates but because of the ability to
switch between characters after a death
this adds an additional layer of
strategy to what would still be an
enjoyable shooter without it one thing
that never gets old is identifying a
weakness of your team or the enemy's
team and then moving into a role that
swings the match in your favor
additional characters and maps seasonal
events and wise design changes have also
ensured the game doesn't get stale and
blizzards track records suggest that the
level of support won't fall off anytime
soon